[Music]
soon so as soon as we hit record then
the noises start so now a little
landscaping a little little construction
uh have you had it through the pandemic
has it been hard kind of doing stuff
like this yeah weirdly it's gotten
easier because it's quieter in our
studio because we share the building
with other tenants and the pandemic
happens and then a lot of them work from
home so now the building's quiet yeah so
that was kind of nice
first of all thanks for joining me
sundar i'm sure you're extremely busy at
this particular time of year so i
appreciate the time one of my favorite
parts of doing this uh
talking tech series is i get to talk to
people who have a unique perspective on
tech and i feel like as a ceo of google
and alphabet
you're almost required to have like some
vision of a future
uh i'm curious the number one question i
always get is what's the next big thing
so i'll just leave you with this number
one faq what is what does the future
hold what are your your big
visions of the next five to ten years of
tech
it's a big question um
you know the in some ways we tried to
communicate aspects of that at yesterday
and i've always felt at google and at
alphabet we are working on
deeper computer science and ai
in a way by which you can you can make
real advances but then take that and
apply it practically to be helpful
be it small moments or bigger moments i
see a lot of potential in the advances
in ai
but it's equally important that you have
a real framework by which you're
applying it right and that's why when we
say helpful we have four attributes we
focus on
knowledge success health and happiness
and i actually think through
the work we do the products i see
and it could be something like in maps
you know adding eco routes or deducting
breaking moments and heartbreaking
moments and making changes
or it could be big like
the mammography example or or derma
assist and so on but you know it's
thinking through with that framework in
mind
definitely i think ai comes up a lot
especially when you watch a google
keynote ai is sort of part of the
solution for almost every problem you
guys solve
uh i wonder
i assume you have to have a pretty
optimistic view about the future of ai
and and the structures you want to keep
in place around it but how much do you
think about the potential negatives or
potential downsides as ai gets more
advanced because i've talked to people
who have a much more negative view about
it no i
i think it's
fair to be worried about worried about
any any new technology you know
technology has dual sites and
i feel humanity's journey has been
at each stage how do you figure out to
harness
technology in a way that benefits
society
and and for ai is so profound i i think
that that will be true for ai too but i
think the way you do it is by
working at it making progress
being transparent about it engaging in
conversations and over time
governments and there have to be other
frameworks to evolve it yeah yeah should
it be up to governments or should it be
up to those
because this is a problem we see all the
time is people who don't know as much
about the thing are in charge of
regulating the thing should it be up to
companies like google to be as
responsible as possible or should there
also be
government
structure around ai a combination of all
that i think companies have to
definitely you know be responsible
because they are
often developing technology early and
you're at the cutting edge of technology
and it takes a while for governments to
you know think about it and address yeah
but i think public private partnerships
are important
academia plays a strong role like an
academic institutions and research
over time for something like ai you
would need
no different for something as big as
climate change you have concepts like
paris agreement
you know you would need global
frameworks because uh to
uh to think about it but i am optimistic
i mean i think you know i see the
benefits of all of the how all of this
can impact and
you know we have worked together hard to
address issues in the past so i think
it's easy to be optimistic because
there's so many good cool things
happening
from ai one of my favorite announcements
from you guys was
google sort of adapting their
computational photography to better
account for different skin tones
and it seems like such a small thing
but it affects so many people i mean
part of the reason i use the cameras
that i do is because it can handle this
latitude and different skin tones and i
like the way they look but i'm curious
if you feel like there's other
quick practical applications of ai in
the smartphone world kind of like that
yeah i definitely think so i was excited
about project douglas you know my
daughter had the same reaction i was you
know she literally had the same reaction
when she first heard about it she's like
was talking about the pictures and she
felt you know she wasn't represented
correctly
and and so
i'm glad we addressed it and there's
more work to be done there
we have had the same experience with
accessibility so live captioning
videos and you can do it on device and
you can and the thing i always like
about these things is even if you
think of it as a
feature to help the disabled community
it has wide applicability beyond that as
well you know you could be in a meeting
and you want to listen to a video and
the captioning still works right and or
in a crowded place and so on so i think
all of this is much wider applicability
too definitely the other ai part that
was a little crazy was
i think it's called lambda
correct me if i'm wrong la mda but you
you demonstrated this uh
conversational aspect of ai where it
sort of uses information
to answer questions about itself so the
demo was talking to pluto which was
pretty cool
you know pluto gets to defend itself
maybe it's a little underrated but i i
imagine like my brain immediately went
to well what other things could you
synthesize a conversation with and i
went straight to like people like other
existing people are there lines you
won't cross with things like project
lambda where like
should you not be allowed to synthesize
conversation with someone who's alive or
how do you think about like where lambda
can go uh
you know i want to stress lambda still
research right and you know so we're
pushing the boundary there
this is why let me step this is why we
you know articulated our ai principles
very clearly and publicly
so that we have a framework to think
through anything like this
when it comes to product i think you
know it's really important
like ai is not ever used in an
impersonation way or you know or
everything through the right constructs
for how it is used and so
we are much more focused on using lambda
to understand language deeper okay and
and in the context you can imagine
talking to google assistant yeah so
first of all search today if it
understood language deeper
or even in youtube when we are trying to
understand what's in a video
right
the fact that we can understand language
deeper would make a big difference so
that's the primary purpose
but in the in in conversing with an
assistant we can make conversations much
more natural
so the intent is into uh you know
pluto and a paper airplane are more
benign examples and but you know we
would have to have
ethical principles and guidelines uh
around anything we developed there
what smartphone do you have in your
pocket and why that's that's probably
the number one question people want me
to ask you
you know it changes a lot uh depends on
the day of the week uh probably not as
many as you play around with
but but someday
you know it may not be too far off
either but i do try out almost every
phone at least for a little bit uh i
shouldn't say every phone most phones
okay um you know but uh
right now in my pocket it's a pixel
actually it should pull it out yeah it
could be any pixel
so you know it's a
it's it's a pixel but it's it's the
released version of the pixel now
but i you know i've enjoyed using the
s21
and uh
you know and
i check out everything that comes in the
market oneplus maybe and you know play
around with it uh iphones across our
products work across everything so i'm
testing a lot of devices yeah it feels
like if you're if you're in
i mean you started at google with
chrome and then
obviously with android and now
overseeing everything
does it ever feel like you're too
in the weeds to appreciate how other
people might use the product because
when i'm making a video for example i
might spend
five six hours on an edit and then i i'm
watching it back looking for little
things and i might kind of lose the
bigger picture of the person who jumps
in for the first time
if you're using android 12 and new
features coming out and you're testing
it on on whatever daily phone it is does
that ever
feel like a challenge to to step back
and remember like people have to use
this for the first time and how they'll
interact with it or do you feel like
you've sort of got that done to a
science no no well
what are you talking it's it's a it's
the art of product management i think
stepping back
so there's a difference between hey
translation is exciting we can build it
in chrome to
how would you do it in a way in which
for most people it kind of naturally
works yeah and and designing it are two
different things i think and so there's
a lot of that
but i actually find your point even
broader a lot of the way when i do
reviews with other teams
the perspective i almost always bring
and it could be anyone else in my
position is
you know because the teams are so in the
effort of what they are doing yeah it's
it's tough for them to sometimes see the
forest
instead of the trees and and so it's a
lot of what real life is about i think i
want to ask about your your like overall
view of
you know becoming a ceo of google like
you grew up in india and you've
mentioned
didn't have access to the internet or a
computer
for a long time and then you came to the
us and you had access to the internet
are there things that still surprise you
about like the advancements in tech and
accessibility today even though you've
seen
so much of a difference between
the beginning of your career and now i
think for me because growing up every
moment was discreet like i had to wait a
long time to get something and then i
saw the impact of it right you know so
waited five years on a waitlist to get a
rotary telephone right and you may not
know what a rotary telephone heard about
this i heard about those
but you know kind of changed the life
for me my parents
in our streets people would come to our
home to kind of use it to talk to their
family and friends
so i've always had that
you know the impact of how it can change
people's lives
where it most directly impacted me is
i got inspired by the one laptop for
child project uh which uh which was
being done by negra ponte at the time
out of mit and
i today look back at chromebooks or you
know android phones and to me feels like
you know it's an explicit continuation
of that journey which which was
inspiring to me right
uh here's maybe an interesting question
uh the
tech ceo
has sort of become like its own genre of
celebrity in a weird way in a way that
it probably wasn't even thought about 10
20 years ago
do you think about that at all like
obviously there's this uh this new
curiosity about some of the most
powerful companies in the world and the
people that run them
being a pretty understated guy i would
assume you're probably not all about the
spotlight but i'm curious what you feel
about that you know i i recognize the
responsibility which comes with it
you know the scale at which tech is
working in the world
uh i think
i think there is an importance to it and
rightfully there is accountability that
comes with it and i think the importance
of engaging and explaining yourselves
internally and externally uh
that comes with it
but beyond that i don't think too much
about it and you know on a day-to-day
basis
it's not how i approach it yeah that's
fair i like that answer
uh
so let's say you fast forward
let's go 50 years into the future
you're retired from
google from tech
how do you want your
your fingerprint here
in the tech world to be remembered
you know uh
i would i would love
allow it to be about
you know enabling radically more access
to both information and computing to
more people
that's a big part of what i think about
you know really
driven by it
but beyond that you know i've always
been interested in
driving deeper technological progress
and
and the
obviously you have to take that and
translate it into product and business
success right and it goes hand in hand
but i think
you know
driving ai forward responsibly uh you
know it's a big part of what i think and
work a lot on for sure
all right well i mean i'm looking
forward to a lot of new stuff that's
coming out
very excited about android 12 and like
all the
customization and and what is it called
something you materialize materially you
like that's it's a cool idea so i'm
looking forward to trying that out but
thanks for the time i appreciate the
interview and hopefully get to it again
sometime all right thanks marcus
appreciate it yeah thanks
[Music]